l'enregistrement audio ok et je lance
sur nom de la cam
ok et là je vais clape et voilà bonjour
à tous j'espère que vous allez bien on
est sur un format un petit peu différent
je vous ai dit ainsi je voulais tenir le
rythme de une vidéo par semaine cette
année il ya certaines vidéos qui allait
être un petit peu plus décontracté
je regarde vraiment toutes les vidéos de
squeeze sauf les trésors heures parce
que j'aime pas trop avoir peur voilà
voilà on a chacun nos petits nos petits
problèmes hockey et j'adore j'adore
juste ma télé ce vrai dit est tout
simple et trop bel et bien ce brennus
qui je trouve correspond pas mal à ce
que je pourrais faire sur la chaîne
c'est un sabre et dit qu'ils s'appellent
âme aille vie
astro astros en anglais c'est astro donc
trou du cul mais en gros ça serait la
traduction se serait genre est ce que je
sais ce que c'est moins l'enfoiré en
gros c'est des gens qui racontent une
histoire et ils ont agi d'une certaine
manière et ils savent pas en fait si
est-ce qu'ils ont été bâtard hop à bata
et donc c'est des questionnements
éthiques c'est des questionnements
moraux moi ça me plaît
moi ça me plaît et en même temps il ya
des gens qui nous racontent leur vie
dont convient une petite touche de
voyeurisme c'est parfait lui évidemment
tout est en anglais et c'est de
l'histoire donc je vais traduire au fur
et à mesure j'espère que ça ira et
j'espère surtout que ça va vous plaire
parce que si ça vous plaît mais moi
j'aimerais bien en faire plusieurs
jamais en faire régulièrement parce que
les gens postent leurs histoires
régulièrement aussi que je pense que ça
peut être très court est-ce que je suis
un [ __ ] parce que j'attends de mon
copain qu'il remplace toutes mes
chaussettes pas exactement les mêmes que
j'avais avant ça a l'air un peu fou je
donc une femme de 24 ans portait des
chaussettes avec des couleurs et ces
machins puisque maintenu et totalement
blanche puisque elle bosse en tant que
phlébotome east qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un flambeau thomistes phlébotome me
l'a filé au poteau me et le processus de
ponctions dans une veine j'ai rarement
dans le bras une canule dans le but de
prélever du sang qu'est ce qu'on y est
on en apprend tous les jours
son uniforme est tout blanc du coin mais
des choses est un peu coloré voilà j'ai
passé quelques années à collecter des
choses est un peu étrange avec des
sushis des pizzas des korgis des chats
nic cage et c'est nicolas sketch [ __ ]
ils disent nikkei de justin ils sont
donc tu refuses et j'avais à peu près 30
perd mon petit copain donc un mec de 29
ans les a toujours détesté
et pense que c'est un truc enfantin l'a
déjà déjà il ya une partie de moi qui se
positionne donc j'étais d'accord pour ne
les portez qu'au travail et jamais leur
donnons rendez vous ou bien avec sa
famille et ses amis en boxing day donc
c'est un jour férié ce jour après noël
le 26 décembre
ses parents sont venus à la maison pour
un café et des cadeaux et précise qu'
ils n'étaient que quatre essais
autorisés
là où ils vivent par barocco vide et ses
malheureuses calais elle met une de ses
paires de chaussettes un peu enfantine
et la mère de son copain lui fait un
commentaire
et elle explique que l les portes au
travail pour faire plaisir à ses
patients et qu' elle qui fait ça mais
que son copain ne l'aimé pas le
lendemain toutes mes chaussettes avait
disparu et le tiroir était remplie avec
des chaussettes noires
j'ai mon petit copain il m'a dit j'ai
été jeté et j'ai racheté des chaussettes
plus approprié comme ça je ne serai pas
embarrassé devant mes parents assez
chaud je lui ai dit que c'était
n'importe quoi que c'était les miennes
et qu'il n'avait pas le droit de les
jeter
sans compter le fait que j'ai passé pas
mal de temps à les collectionner
donc je lui ai fait liste de celles dont
je me souvenais et je lui dis que
j'attendais exactement les mêmes en
remplacement il m'a dit que c'était
totalement déraisonnée que ça lui
prendrait beaucoup de temps d'efforts
d'argent pour trouver ces paires de
chaussettes aussi spécifique bah oui bah
évidemment que ça prend du temps
d'effort de l'argent c'est justement ce
que elle elle avait pendant des années
et c'est ce que tu as jeté bâtard m et 1
et dit merci beaucoup pour vos réponses
je réalise que c'est peut-être pas une
dispute normal et je suis en train de
repenser la relation bien sûr bien sûr
mais à quel moment tu jettes toutes les
chaussettes de ton mec ou ta meuf quoi
enfin je veux dire apparemment c'est une
propriété privée voilà enfin la
propriété privée on va dire des gros
mots et à l'écran attention c'est une
propriété privée
je vois pas à quel moment le mec à ce
droit
de jeter des affaires à partir du moment
où des majeurs et que c'est pas tes
parents et même si tu étais mineur et 7
des parents seraient discutables le mec
a touché at-on autonomie en fait
finalement appartement où il a fait ça à
la question est ce que tu es d'enfoirés
la réponse est évidemment non non pas
contre lui
si je peux me permettre bel [ __ ]
est-ce que je suis un [ __ ] de ne pas
utiliser l'argent qui était dédiée au
cra orange de ma fille pour payer la
désintox de mon beau fils alors là en
terme d'éthique etc
c'est beaucoup plus coton que les
chaussettes à à vous laver ou coton les
choses à kayes mon mari et moi on était
marié depuis trois ans on a une fille
qui a 15 ans il a un fils qui à 24 ans
je suis très cordiales avec mon beau
fils mais on n'est pas proche il a une
mère biologique qui est fermée très très
bien j'ai pas envie de prendre le rôle
de mère ok fair enough très bien mon
mari précédemment que le père de ma
fille est mort quand ma fille avait six
ans on avait tous les deux contribué à
l'argent qui devait servir à son crâne
aux états unis ça coûterait cher les
études
voilà le genre de questionnement que on
n'aurait pas chez nous c'est un peu
comme la série breaking bad c'est bien
un truc qui pourrait pas arriver en
france et d'ailleurs les grands parents
du côté du père de ma fille donc le père
qui est décédé ont contribué énormément
à cet argent à combien s'élève cet
argent 180 mille dollars
pas mal pas mal quand même ma fille est
extrêmement brillant c'est je le dis pas
juste parce que je suis sa mère je pense
vraiment qu'elle a les capacités d'aller
dans une ville x couleurs les school ivy
league c'est les écoles type harvard
yale
on gagne trop d'argent pour avoir
n'importe quelle aide financière mon
mari actuel et moi on a des finances
séparées et ils ne contribuent pas du
tout à ce fonds pour les études de ma
fille alors qu'est-ce qui vient [ __ ]
la merde dans cette histoire mon beau
fils il galère avec une addiction à
l'héroïne et nous a volé de l'argent
nous a volé des bijoux des matériaux
électroniques etc pour payer sa drogue
précise dit je comprends que l'addiction
c'est une maladie et j'ai payé
personnellement une adapation détox pour
lui qui m'a coûté 1000 $ et qui a échoué
alors je sais pas ce que c'est une note
paint détox alors ce que je comprends de
ce que c'est une aop jeunes des toc sont
dans la journée et c'est raté en détox
et tout mais le soir tu peux rentrer
chez toi c'est pas un truc de détox ou
serait ce là bas jour et nuit donc
a priori moins efficace et donc ça a
échoué
donc elle a déjà payé 1000 elle a déjà
payé 1000 $ pour ensuite son père il a
payé pour un autre pêcheur rihab
programme qui a coûté 6500 $ et qui n'a
pas marché non plus parce que il s'est à
peine pointe et autres il nous a promis
qu'ils feraient mieux la prochaine fois
et qu'il avait besoin d'une autre chance
donc on a refait un homme pécheur lui à
programme à 6500 $ qu'on a partagé avec
mon mari ça a marché pendant un
programme et ensuite ils les retombées
dedans dès qu'il en est sorti j'ai
dépensé tellement d'argent de temps et
d'énergie et nous a pas du tout aidé mon
mari et mon beau fils veulent essayer un
sixties est donc un truc de 60 jours où
pendant 60 jours il est dans un centre
et ça ça coûterait 30 mille dollars est
absolument aucune idée d'où est-ce
qu'ils vont prendre cet argent vu tous
les milliers de dollars qu on a déjà
dépensé et le fait qu' on n'a plus rien
de valeur dans notre maison ils veulent
utiliser les tunes de ma fille sauf que
le veille walt est assez assez
intéressant mais encore une fois on est
dans ce truc comme avec les chaussettes
ou on se mêle de quelque chose qui nous
vraiment nous appartient pas quoi which
to mise
absolute et off limits qui pour moi est
hors de question ça dépasse les limites
j'ai l'intention c'est complètement
injuste vis-à-vis de ma fille et c'est
aussi injuste vis-à-vis de mon précédent
mari et de ses parents mon mari pense
que je suis une [ __ ] à ce que je
priorise l'éducation de la fille par
rapport à la vie de son fils et il pense
que la santé devrait venir en premier
assez intéressant ils en chient demande
à ma fille si elle était ok de dépenser
30 mille dollars de son fonds pour payer
la désintox de son beau frère et elle a
été très silencieuse elle a pas répondu
du coup elle a répondu en fait je vous
le dis pour info dans ces cas là quand
on répond pas et ensuite il s'est énervé
contre elle et il a dit qu'il était
égoïste
ma fille m'a ensuite dit qu'elle ne
voulait pas donner l'argent à son beau
frère
mais que s anté hyper coupable et je
suis furieuse envers mon mari d'avoir
culpabiliser ma fille de 10 ans or
est-ce que je suis une enfant alors la
première réaction c'est quand même de
dire non non ce n'est pas une en foire
est tu vois je pense que ça va être
intéressant cette vidéo parce qu'on va
tout savoir des raisons différents
points par exemple le fait que son mari
a contribué énormément à cette cagnotte
et que
et ses grands parents paternels extra
qui ont contribué le fait qu'il soit
décédé j'avoue ça me touche
particulièrement serait un peu le trahir
quoi et en même temps l'argument du mari
qui est de dire que la santé passe avant
l'éducation et en plus c'est qu'on parle
de mon éducation high level réf
l'argument de passer à la santé avant se
défend se défend aussi et le fait qu'il
ait eu pas mal de chance joue en faveur
de la mer clairement parmi vous beaucoup
sont choqués par la question est pour
vous la question se pose même pas il
faudrait dépenser ses 30000 dollars
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué alors
qu'est ce que ça dit dans les
commentaires il ya eu trois mille
commentaires
donc c'est un commentaire qui citent le
fait qu' ils veulent utiliser l'argent
de sa fille
ce qui pour elle n'a aucun sens et
dépasse les limites et le gars dit donc
ses tarifs au max qui dit ça ne dépend
pas de toit ni deux ni de personne
c'est l'argent de ta fille ton ancien
mari a payé pour ça les grands parents
paternels ont payé pour ça tu as payé
pour ça mais c'est pour elle pas pour un
enfant dont la moitié de ces gens ne
connaissent pas ensuite le commentaire
rebondit aussi sur le fait que le mari
s'est fâché avec la fille ce qui j'avoue
je trouve n'a aucun sens le fiel à quel
âge rappelons le à la 16 ans je crois 15
ans à 15 ans tu va confronter la fissure
de l'argent ça c'est pas cool ça ne
devrait pas être est ce que je suis une
[ __ ] pour avoir refusé ses devrait
être ok donc j'ai quitté ce mec parce
qu'il a dépassé les limites et il a fait
en sorte que ma fille se sentent mal et
culpabilise à cause de quelqu'un qui a
une addiction parce qu'elle voulait pas
lui donner trente mille dollars qui
étaient destinés à son futur elle est le
commentaire ajoute la diction est un
vrai problème et je suis désolée pour
ton beau fils et son père mais je suis
pas assez désolé pour excuser ce qu'ils
sont en train d'essayer de faire cet
enfant tu as volé de l'argent est à
propriété et maintenant ils essaient de
voler le futur de ta fille waouh c'est
vrai que jusqu où on va pour aider
quelqu'un qui a un problème et c'est
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller
et qu'est ce qu'on est prêt à sacrifier
pour ça après ouais et à des questions
qui se posent les commentaires vite fait
de mal témoignage d'une meuf qui qui
était avec un qui a eu un père
alcoolique et un mari qui galérait avec
la sobriété et c est le la personne dit
me retirer et l'aimer et prendre du
temps pour moi et pour mon fils ça a été
ce qui m'a ramené en fait un état
beaucoup plus sain et quand le
l'addiction était seulement son problème
c'est ça qui lui a sauvé la vie
on a une expression juste après don't
like you know and fire to keep très joli
alors ne vous mettez pas en feu pour
réchauffer les autres sasebo [ __ ]
après je pense que la solution c'est ce
commentaire là il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller dans un riad à 30000 dollars et
qui explique en gros qui a l'air assez
assez calé sur l'épreuve d'addiction etc
et qui expliquent voilà tout le tous les
processus d'affaires aux etats-unis pour
pouvoir se faire aider sans payer trente
mille dollars quoi la russie un [ __ ]
au final cette femme tracé complexe
c'est complexe mais en même temps on est
là pour ça non on est là pour ce genre
de situation un peu complexe je pense
que la messe n'est pas une un seul non
plus quoi je pense que c'est terrible
c'est dur mais c'est pas parce que c'est
dur et qu'on donne pas à la personne qui
souffre qu'elle veut ou ce dont elle a
besoin qu'on est forcément un [ __ ] en
fait c'est normal d'avoir ses intérêts
c'est normal de vouloir protéger ce qui
nous revient protéger ses enfants je
chope avoir votre avis en commentaire je
pense qu'on va je pense qu'on va avoir
des avis très différent parfois certains
et certaines d'entre vous est ce que je
suis une [ __ ] pour a repris le
cadeau de mes grands parents qui étaient
destinés à mon fiancé et l'avoir donné
chaque année mes grands-parents et donne
300 dollars à leurs petits enfants et
500 dollars alors petits enfants qui
sont maria c'est discutable
enfin j'imagine qu'ils les donnent en
couple donc ok c'est marrant ces genres
de c'est marrant les petites coutume qui
a dans chaque famille comme ça ok donc
quand on a ouvert nos cadeaux
j'ai remarqué cette année que mon cousin
qui s'est récemment mariée avec son
petit ami gay ils ont reçu 300 $ alors
que moi et mon fiancé
on a reçu 500 dollars donc j'ai pris 200
$ de l'envelope et je les donner à mon
cousin devant tout le monde
ce qui a créé une scène très très
audacieux très audacieux moi je pense
que j'aurais donné du coût 100 dollars
histoire que tout le monde ait la même
chose ma famille est très religieuse et
ne refusent d'accepter le mariage gay
voilà il refuse de reconnaître le son
mari comme un membre de famille et lui
disent d'aller en enfer
sauf s'il change sont lifesize yes
[ __ ] mais quelle belle famille sa
faiblesse que j'ai défendu ma décision
en disant on n'est pas marié encore ils
le sont à auch avoue ok donc
effectivement j'aurais fait 500 300 et
je pense qu'il ya une erreur
j'adore j'adore la petite pointe de
naïveté je pense qu'il ya une erreur et
tout j'adore ça j'aime bien ce move la
compensation est parti vite fait en
cacahuète et donc du coup mon cousin et
moi on est vite partie de la rhino samy
est ce que ma famille me disais que
c'était pas mon argent et donc que mon
action a manqué de respect à mes
grands-parents et à mon fiancé aussi
pardon en fait depuis début je pensais
que c'était une meuf qui parlait en fait
c'est un mec est donc c'est sa fiancée
ma fiancée a l'impression que ma famille
était en train de l'accueillir et que je
les rejeter devant tout le peuple est
mon cousin nous amène à dîner pour le
nouvel an avec les deux sondeurs
parce que vous avez des restaurants
ouverts il ya socket est ce que je suis
un [ __ ]
non je pense pas l'un c'est chiant
vis-à-vis des grands parents et petits
mots au genre même si les grands-parents
tu as ils ont des valeurs que tu trouves
naze peut-être ce qui est mal à
embrasser le faire devant eux quoi et
âme dans non parce que c'est important
qu'ils comprennent aussi que voilà
il faut accepter ce cousin et
l'homosexualité de cette partie de la
famille quoi parents de la fiancée pas
très très cool hein elle aurait pu dire
vas-y de l'argent évidemment ça fait
plaisir et c'est un homme en fait mais
plus j'y pense et moins tu es un assaut
le par contre tu es entouré un peu
d'assaut l'un si je peux me permettre
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya
certains sujets la société d'une
certaine manière nous a déjà dit ce
qu'il était bon de penser ou non c'est
pas une critique c'est un fait quoi à
l'échelle de la société l'homophobie
c'est un énorme problème et c'est pas
bien toi et ont donc on condamne ça mais
à l'échelle de la société entre un
problème d'addiction est une opportunité
d'éducation c'est beaucoup moins clair
il ya plein de valeurs qui se mélangent
et donc c'est beaucoup moins clair qu'un
problème d'homophobie quoi ou un
problème d'homophobie bon bah c'est
condamnable c'est fini ciao on va
s'arrêter là les amis c'est un essai là
je sais pas du tout combien de temps la
durée la vidéo je sais pas si c'est je
sais pas si ça va être intéressant
marenches chiant j'en ai aucune idée
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle vidéo prenez soin de vous
ne faites pas des trucs d'enfoirés love
peace now
[Musique]